I'm fine my name is s and how can I help
you um yeah I'm looking for Miss Jenny
Summers busy today maybe you give me
your name my name is Axel Foley and what
is
paining I didn't understand what you
said paining what it's meaning regarding
oh what's it regarding I'm an old
acquaintance at first
d one
moment only R tell me Summer that Mr
ammed f is here to see Axel F Axel a aw
Axel F is here to see her these all the
qu Don this cover this it's like the bre
of a dog to scrub for the customer it's
not sexy it's animal that's not sexy at
all have you something to drink a wine a
cotile
a
espresso no I'm fine thank you I make it
to myself right back there with a little
lemon twist it's good should try it no
I'm I'm fine I see you look at this base
yeah I was wondering how much something
like this went for
$130,000 get the out of here no I
cannot it's serious because it's very
important base have you ever sold one of
these sell it yesterday to a collector
get the out of some El I said it
myself Axel Foy what on Earth are you
doing here how you doing I'm fine hold a
second I'll be right down great excuse
me
Serge off me
man get the off we play games man
hey I'm
some
hey the is
this did you see this I can
describe all of them please move to the
side of the car put your your hands on
the hood why what's with you guys you
heard what he said sir do it right now
please what kind of is this man
hold up wait a second you guys are
arresting me for getting thrown out of a
window I got thrown out of a
window man gun
partner sir you are under arrest you
have the right to remain silent anything
you say can and will be used against you
in a court of law you have the right to
have an attorney present during
questioning yeah I understand I
understand the right I know this is
though man I got some out of a
window please get in the car sir
y but tell me something what's the
charge possession of a concealed weapon
and disturbing the piece disturbing the
piece I got thrown out of a window
what's the charge for getting
pushed out of a moving car huh jayw
walking this is I'm Sergeant
tager and this is my partner detective
Rosewood you always treat visitors from
out of town like
this why didn't you identify yourself as
a police officer when you were arrested
cuz I was minding my own business
business where the do you guys get
off on arresting somebody for getting
thrown out of a window we have six
witnesses that say you broke in and
started tearing up the place then jumped
out the window and you guys believe that
what the are you cops or doormen
we're more likely to believe an
important local businessman than a foul
mouth jerk from out of town foul mouth
you
man you watch your mouth hey man don't
square off on me with some you
want to start some static hey don't push
me you
minute
tager yes
sir come
here
sir I apologize for striking
you
I have no
excuse forget about it detective Foley
I'm Lieutenant bill of the Beverly Hills
Police Department do you wish to file
charges against Sergeant
tager this is some kind of joke right do
you wish to file charges against this
officer for
assault look where I'm from cops don't
file charges against other
cops no I don't want to do
that well in Beverly Hills we go
strictly by the
book now why didn't you inform us when
you came to town I'm on vacation well if
you're on vacation what business did you
have in Victor Maitland's office I had
to go to the bathroom I was walking by
it looked like a nice clean place so I
stop you always take your gun on
vacation I don't know I never been on
vacation before I need a couple of
bananas how much are it well the buffet
plate is 12250 you get peaches plums
Orange oranges and bananas all I need is
a couple of
bananas Shh go ahead take those
bananas
hey forget it I'm not eating that take
it back certainly sir this really looks
great
can I get some uh extra mayo certainly
sir thank
you ready to go
yeah there's the Mercedes we get rid of
that
[Music]
stuff what the hell are you doing
a
[Music]
[Applause]
a
you going to hang around here
[Music]
[Applause]
no fre it hold it right
there oh
AEL be careful old boy it might hit
me
pleas hey man take off your
glasses I thought that was you man you
almost got busted I did get busted I
lost my whole investment because of you
VIN what the hell is wrong with you man
you know I'm a businessman I got to work
you coming side at half hour late and on
top of all that you going to bring the
goddamn cop with you to what are you
talking cop he ain't no cop that's Dirty
Harry himself man what the is wrong
with you going to bring him in here you
calling me a cop you definitely a cop he
ain't no cop he's my nephew well the
dude is definitely bad luck I don't know
what he is to you he's bad luck to me
bad luck I'll tell you what's
bad luck my friends in the prison body
shop fixing all the cars and he smash
that day cuz you had to around this
guy's a clown what wait a second
what the cop
maning why can't I check you if he Ain
cop if he ain't why can't
I St why won't let meis him then cut the
cut the cut the
man look I got 2,000 blank
American Express cards right now gold
you got the money you want to do
business or what I have the money and I
do want to do business but with you I
ain't doing nothing in front of this
dude cuz this dude is a cop I know when
I can smell a pig inside the room I used
to be a Muslim man and I know that's
park over here and then yes Park it's
definitely Park I ain't doing
around this dude man you want to do
business you know where to find me
you man you call me come here come here
hey hey hey what the hell's going on
here who the hell are you uh Chief this
is shut up
Rosewood uh my name is Johnny wish
Wishbone johanny Wishbone and I a
psychic from the island of St Croy yes I
a psychic from the island of St Croy and
I read in the St Croy cazette that the
Beverly Hills Police Department having
some trouble figuring out crimes so what
I did was come to Beverly Hills to help
the police out they tell me they don't
want my help they don't need my help so
I'm going to go on my Merry way I'm a
psychic I a psychic phenomenon watch
this I don't know who you are but watch
this um your name is um
Luts right Chief Luts that's your name
see the name pop inside my head like
that and your name is um
um BD bidd yes see I you give two more
seconds I would say to myself I don't
need no help from no one because I'm
Johnny Wishbone psychic extraordinaire
if you need me just think Johnny
Wishbone and I come running lots and
biddles it's like KES and bits but
different excuse me sorry to bother you
your name is joh
right what the hell is going on here
what is this a magic show get the H I'm
going to have your badges if you don't
go to traffic dude do you hear me get
out of
here hi I'm K fry assistant manager how
are you Carla nice to meet you beautiful
place you have here my name is uh
Richard James and it's very nice to meet
you Ross could I see you for a
minute I'll be right back take your time
Russ God damn that's a big
[Music]
natur I can see yeah yeah I mean I I
understand wait somebody want wait y oh
oh oh come right in don't let the fact
that my doors closed dissuade you in any
way from entering my office sir we're at
the Beverly Hills Police Department are
you Mr syney Bernstein yes lucky guess
well sir you have 25 unpaid parking
tickets we have a warrant for your
arrest 25 what 25 what 25 unpaid parking
tickets sir I I pay my tickets I pay I
pay all my tickets sir do you want a
black Mercedes-Benz license plates
number crl 507 507 that's my wife's car
that's not my car that's my 2500 it's my
name but it's my wife's car no no no
tickets have not been paid that
means you're liable can you cuff Mr
Bernstein please cuff me there are
people out there with chainsaws you're
cuffing me well sir you have 25 unpaid
parking tickets and it's your car so we
have to take you in wait a second I've
got an idea is there something that I
have in this office that I could hand to
you and that would make you kind of
forget that you're holding those uh
little pink tickets there what are you
trying to say Sir like you'd be holding
something in that hand and this hand
you'd forget about this hand you'd be
concentrating on that hand you'd go what
what did I have there I don't even
remember Oh you mean like if I had
um $200 in his hand ouch let go of my
arm
$200 ouch please I'm robbing you that's
what I'm doing here's one here two
they're real crisp well now you think
about Mr BN yes yeah I'm going have to
use your uh computer because I have to
wipe all all evidence of this
transaction out you know no problem no
problem at all thank you Sydney so much
oh oh certainly certainly also I mean um
I'm quite sure man in your position
understands that uh my contact down at
headquarters would want his name to be
known don't I know it don't I know could
you excuse me for a second while I oh
you're going to just yeah secret it it's
like a James Bond thing sure yes yes yes
thank you no problem hey no problem at
all anything you want to use
I can't believe what I don't want to
hear it Billy Billy you sure you know
what you're doing trust
[Music]
me come
onel
get
him get
down
[Music]
behind pul pin
Billy what are you doing
extend pull open it wow Billy release
safety
Billy aim through there push
[Music]
this Rambo
get
[Music]
the cover me
goel
[Music]
what the hell have you done here looks
like a goddamn war zone what the hell
have you done here tager tell me we
solved the alphabet crimes you shut up
who the hell is talking to you I
personally solv the alphabet case up in
a body bag over an hour
ago and you I don't give a goddamn what
federal agency you say you're working
for you're in jail buddy Chief wait a
minut shut up what the hell do you think
you're doing here bringing down a
firefight in the middle of my city
you're out of the cop business for good
forever will you just listen a minute
shut up you shut your mouth once and for
all no godamn it you shut up this is
what the alphabet crimes are all about
guns guns that guy sold them and then
bought him with stolen money from
Adriano and his own racetrack he was on
his way to Central America and if you'd
bother to take your head out of your ass
you'd see we'd saw the whole goddamn
thing you watch yourself just a minute
Lut why didn't I know about this because
Chief Lut doesn't have the guts to hear
the truth from real cops that's why we
had to go under cover with Detective
Foley to solve this case that cuts a
taget you're fired yeah kiss my ass kiss
mine you're fired too Lutz isn't that
right I think I've just about had it
with your abusive attitude I'm sorry I
get carried away I'm sorry you are fired
do you understand that don't overreact
Ted please you're fired I want you out
of here
now get out of here fired you regret
this Ted I regret it now I've regret it
for the last two months you're fir
you're out of here get out of here will
you get out get out are they civilians
now you bet I'mma kick your ass
later Axel thank you so much really I've
got to go to a charity meeting food for
the homeless for Beverly Hills food for
the homeless I'd like to make a donation
sir it's $200 in the name of Sydney
Bernstein that's my Alias I don't like a
lot of publicity thank you Axel I mean
Sydney Bernstein thank you gentlemen
very much thank you sir thank
you if you get your head out of your ass
long enough kiss my
ass you're getting more and more like me
every day next thing you know you're
going to have afro big
dicks
we got a
tail wax that
[Music]
[Applause]
clown
[Music]
damn
it
[Music]
help me
man I'm over
you
where you're
walk keep
the keep
the
[Music]
your
favor
[Music]
excuse
me hey that's not fair maintenance I got
to go Breeze the chain you hear how dry
it sound
sorry come on let's
go
[Music]
hi
you see this rope we're going to try to
slide down this rope all the way to the
ground we
are you're going to
try give me a hand I want you to come up
and hold onto my
neck come on it's
okay you're going to grab onto my neck
really tight okay come on come on hold
on really tight now hold on tight
[Music]
give me your
hand come on stop it give me your hand
it's okay come on it's
okay come
[Music]
on hang on hang on
tight
come on come on
[Music]
up
now I'm going to show you something that
is going to totally blow your rocks off
it's absolutely orgasmic and my most
thing that I'm proud of it's the most up
to-date the ultimate survival tool for
today the dawn of a new generation in
luxury personal Weaponry the annihilator
20 000 is America's Premier survival
home and travel Total Security unit the
annihilator 2000 is a lightweight high
performance weapon that meets the
demands of the new generation of upper
income Urban
survivalists the annihilated 2000 has
the conveniences of a cellular telephone
with fax machine and a microwave
oven night vision goggles micro
processor verbal alarm systems a compact
disk player digital AM FM radio video
camera and Playback functions are just a
few of the features of the extraordinary
Annihilator 2000 you think those are
real stopping power is a matter of
convenience with your annihilated
2000 that's Dodie my personal
trainer she can bench press 200
lb she's working on reducing my body fat
but it's really difficult because I keep
sneaking away to have a go cheese I
don't care I wear sus the annihilator
000 is constructed of a lightweight
aluminum alloy combined with the new
polymer technology making it totally
resistant to
corrosion the dawn of a new generation
in luxury personal Weaponry the
annihilator 2000 is America's Premier
survival home and travel Total Security
unit now who the hell is going to buy
that are you joking this is a li
I'm selling hundreds of these it's on
back order get the out of here no I
cannot because I am trying to to tell
you I sell 10 of these to Jackie
Stallone for stalking stuffers get the
out of here Sly come in and bought
14 Zaza Gabor has one AA has one we got
to go thanks sir thanks a well try to
say s it's not so difficult Serge sounds
like a detergent Foley is heading for
alien
attack
attention attention this is a red alert
alien spacecraft are invading the City
Board the subway trains for immediate
[Music]
evacuation
run run run
[Applause]
[Music]
a he ran up those
stairs